sono appena arrivato all'unrae c'è un
maestro un pochino perché non mi volevo
far passare hanno visto il mio
passaporto e ci hanno messo qualcosa
tipo 30 minuti per farmi diciamo andare
avanti e io ero tentatissimo di
chiedergli se si fosse perché non
assomigliasse alla foto che dire se ero
venuto peggio in foto ossero peggio dal
vivo una curiosità che però forse fatto
bene a tenerli per me perché ai
controlli sicurezza magari acconterebbe
essere un po più serio
direttamente
[Musica]
dobbiamo ora andarci a carmine a 5
pertanto
non ho ancora la febbre
quando 138 però deciso di uscire per
quanto non può uscire assolutamente e
poi non stare appetito tesoro ascoltami
hai avuto la febbre quasi a 40 il
crimine non aspetta il crimine una
svolta ma se devo andare
no no l'ho conosciuto un'altra il mio
abito stai facendo diventare pazzi al
freddo
ottimo lo so si sta facendo la toscana
cagliari sta guardando con gli occhi
fissi dopo passo parlarmi a te lo passo
dalla verità non possiamo aspettare ma
dice la vacanza ma sciolti
grazie mille londra mercato non si potra
e mezza già sesta fa buio
però io ti amo ti amo con tutto il cuore
dobbiamo andare a novo una buca che si
chiama come si chiamano tende modi non
mi guarda che cos'ha detto fatto trovare
non so se è il servizio è il servizio
norma che carini però che cosa piccolo
gesto possa stabilire rende ancora più
speciale la spiaggia a londra gli auguro
il meglio
continuate così e bella seguiti da
lontano e stari most accompagnato prima
ma che carina
no già da ragazzo sul serio siamo al
nobu usato guardare questa parete che
cos'è tupin stupendo stupendo un mii
postillo un bagno pil non scherzi a
parte già da che tu sia benedetta
cercando di essere chic come questa con
le forchette ma continuo a monigo
strappando a morsi
ma tra tosa e sdraiato io l'ho mai
assaggiato vedere che lui un pochino gn
cui solo rossetto voglio chiedere
pubblicamente perdono a tutti quanti per
l'arredo qualità ma purtroppo sto
guidando e quindi non posso fare
altrimenti signora che cosa vuole fare
fatta lei astri grazie a tra l'altro
sembrerà di stare anche sulle montagne
russe vedove essere di un senso di
nausea non vi preoccupate sono solo le
famose buchi di roma sta andando a
cercare un ufficio perché perché quello
che avevamo visto ce l'hanno soffiato
hanno avuto un'offerta prima di noi
ora mi sentirò anche con un già marzo
selvatico pochettino suddivisi i vari
annunci su roma mazza che fa e pippa
giganti era che sta attaccando alle
persone cercheremo di trovare qualche
cosa
dato che sta guidando non posso sto fare
la registrazione in giro per roma con me
stiamo andando dopo st buffa ta diciamo
offerteci tacciata la nostra salvatrice
a dei mercatini vintage qui per lavoro
sì esatto cioè abbiamo unito diciamo
l'utile al dilettevole che in realtà
cosa mi fa piacere perché comunque è una
roba divertente vedere delle cose nuove
dei vestiti ecco per dirne una e poi
andremo a mangiare forse uno dei miei
posti preferiti dunque non so voi ma
ogni volta giusto a londra a cristo
sempre essere vestito e macchine anche
perché non riesco a capire dove guardare
come ricerca come lavoro
i ragazzi si parla della malattia di
questi l'economia poveri fanno quale fa
parte dei commenti lasciati più ness
lamiere piangere ma la bravura poi con
la quale lo fanno gli poco commosso
ma perché sa che ci metterà da casa
mente il salmone esatto insomma questo
posto di leggeri
capasanta
così carne
[Musica]
sistema cembra schifo un nuovo secondo
me tu o io o forse lo sa che mio tutti
perché in modo meno mi ha visto il buon
sopra
non so nemmeno che cosa quella moderata
ma non ti vergogni
un'altra strada
se almeno noi ci diamo
l'ex di pesce anche col calore iniziano
a muoversi
a buonissimo ci vuole troppo provare a
rifarli a cucina buttata ho il terrore
di stuprarle un po sei risorto è
veramente sto ancora male
ecco come dire sta lontano guarda che
tenete farebbe male potere io ho due
chili o presso in via b1 dove dovrebbe
fino al 2021 per tornare sovrappeso ma
non parlo è quasi fa vero schifo aveva
fatto un pit stop ma sappi che un altro
posto che io adoro
quale prende in sushi così molto
velocemente lo trovi a abbastanza
economico mangi subito così appena
finito di mangiare l'art che bello
sempre molte riprese favolose a mezza
tacca chiama jean marzo per sapere come
sia andata la sua ricerca dell'ufficio
da marco c day dal the chiaro come la va
molto bene molto bene fai oggi mi sono
dilettato in una fase di riprese del
blog che ho fatto delle riprese come le
fai tu col video davanti ea mezza aperta
io invece sto commettendo inquadrature
con lavandini semplicemente insegna ad
essere come te spielberg volevo sapere
come fosse andata le tue ricerca perchè
la mia è stata tragicomica ti dico solo
che sembrano a vedere un ufficio senza
il bagno però c'erano le foto del bagno
su internet
eh sì pure a me dispiace un sacco perché
quello mi piaceva un sacco cantare
subito
a chiudere quando è così è infatti
bisogna andarli a vedere tutti quanti
insieme così proprio democrazia oppure
doc a fidarsi del giudizio di uno solo
che però non si earl e perché non sarà
certo se vogliamo venerdì possiamo
prendere un appuntamento
e allora si fidano immediatamente io
venerdì non ci sono sono a torino però
mi fido del vostro giudizio cioè se
siete tu e guglielmo fece pure un po
oltre
ottimo noi e basta tanto che stiamo
tutti quanti insieme se le news
ti faccio sapere comunque vada già con
la proposta in mano allora dài
aggiorniamo ok il bacio grande ciao come
si chiude ma è ufficiale i biglietti
della metro sono una rapina del
biglietto è andato per la vita
ho pagato di 15 euro per i soldi
allora un messaggio alla famiglia di lui
sappiate che se il vostro figlio ancora
vivo e grazie a me lui arriva qua siamo
a regent street e mi fa ovvio mi
raccomando occhio a tutti quanti gli
autobus che quantificano sotto senza
problemi mette piede nella strada
a quel punto contro di lui per un
autobus pronto a tranciare l'ho io l'ho
tirato di nuovo dentro el ho salvato è
questa qui è semplicemente un piccolo
squarcio della nostra relazione delle
sei dove sei nascosto ringrazio
ringraziamento magari è toccato a me
oggi luigi mi sta portando i nuovi suoi
ristoranti preferiti che si chiama
questo è un menu che non lo scanner
anche io
e la cosa positiva è che abbiamo preso
delle bistecche patatine fritte al
partito se gli spinaci i ritiri
formativo
cioè secondo me mangiare londra 21 posto
di magia di otto militari comunque non
entra nell'ambito amen
c'è questo problema non lo sai che non è
tenera e una 50 di nati dispersione
abbiamo una bistecca o patatine al
tartufo che presidente prima classe
[Musica]
stessa cosa
con pepe nero da mettere sopra
e tanti spinaci a crema cioè con
formaggio
questo mi sembra un doppio mento ma
perché quando mangiamoci rispondiamo
ecologia non c'è più il doppio mento
adesso sembra un uovo allora ciao
ragazzi sono da marco il nostro produce
ufficiale non mi dire che lo stiamo
facendo veramente mi sa che avremo una
minuscola anticipazione su quello che
sarà la traccia illuminaci ma non
dobbiamo registrare un po di effetti
speciali
vai coi sound f poi si potrebbe servire
un bel bip bene direi che possiamo
concludere con questo rivederci
adesso siamo all'interno del liberty che
enorme c'è questo leggo far vedere che
siamo sei piani complessivi e poi
girando avanti da una sezione perché
enormi ragazzi questo lo stop enorme
cosa voglio su per darvi l'idea di una
delle sezioni da bellissimo sfumando n
nissimo sloveni dove bellissimo
in questo momento sto fingendo di
parlare per poi far vedere una cosa sta
tenendo le prime possiamo una ragazza
nel caso un di godino sulla fronte non
lo vedete
poi esce da questo posto e ai il fioraio
è meraviglioso è enorme occhio perché
stai nella strada
tu eri con un piede nella strada dando
le spalle alle macchine che vengono da
quel lato niente
il papa cosiddetta il papa
cartacea che non si sa mai
no non sono mai venuto la liberty e
manco lo conosceva lo diciamo più di
sonno
tanti soldi perché la caratteristica dei
liberti e che tu devi almeno comunque
mollare da un rene a una mano c'è un
pezzo del tuo corpo per poter uscire con
un pezzo loro ma se siete molto ricchi
potete sicuramente venire qua o
complementare nei migliori amici e
donatori una piccola premessa se la
nutrita five guys ci siamo sfollati 2 il
ceco la palla e questa ragazza stupenda
è venuto a salutarci e il ragazzo ci ha
offerto dei sicuri
ora lui non c'è perché sta prendendo la
coca cola e quindi è carina grazie
grazie
perché ha detto che non si poteva non
venire qua senza prendere giu sgorgare
mamma
buongiorno signori possiamo parlare
della bellezza di questa maglione di
luigi economista fatto comunque faremo
altri giri di lavoro per lui poi andremo
a mangiare e poi inizieremo a prepararci
per l'evento di premi video per un po il
terrore io personalmente di non avere
azzeccato il vestito già parte di non
entrare il vestito ma la paura è quella
di avere un vestito che non c'è quello
degli altri piccolo aggiornamento
abbiamo scoperto che dovevamo cambiare
look all'ultimo perché lui pensava che
dovessimo essere superfici ma anch'io in
realtà e quindi alla fine cosa è
successo che avevamo un outfit super
elegante non sono detto ma noi più
scialla bene siamo corsi a patata amo
fare le cose all'ultimo specialmente
quando sono ben pianificate va beh lo
stava aspettando il nostro huber e
torniamo verso l'albergo
eccoci alla fine qui da un posto che non
ci piace molto non me lo è per niente
andare un club inglese è stato che la
più portato da questo che fa parlò dove
respiri oli o nell'aria e la nasa che ha
fatto molto bisogno dell'area io mi sono
preso questo volevo tanto un buon
fish'n'chips va beh diciamo che sarebbe
la prossima continua
a pieni polmoni arrivatami disco scusa
di niente sempre un posto così elegante
che vergogna ecco io voglio una donna
fruttare nel buco di nola che ti sei
comprato una cosa qualcuno mi fermi no
deve inquadrare in modo che sembri uno
che mangia qualcuno mi fermi e mi al
ragù nonostante tu sia a londra stia
spassando noi stiamo qui con tortellini
in preparazione guardate che meraviglia
altro che cucina buttata guarda ma anche
a bologna vengono chiusi così per lei
perché non ci sono per te mi raccomando
riso pollo verdurine la cosa leggerina
devi mettere attimino formare brodo di
gallina come si deve tutto nei ragazzi
direzione leicester scolanti all'odio
ti voglio vedere la lontana stranieri ma
ti pare che la rinuncia per ora vedesse
a star trek anche quelli giusti così
nicolardi
[Musica]
praticamente siamo qua dietro si possono
vedere tutti i quali sono le persone che
hanno un lavoro pazzesco le anteprime a
leicester square sono pazzesche però io
video per vedere lei ben idolo con meno
sette gradi che cedute a sorridere ma
sembra una persona o sembrati una mezza
idea ma se non è perché non sento più
niente non sente più nulla del freddo e
si attesta a 3 patita con questo quel
momento in cui sto facendo un video
solamente per togliermi dall'imbarazzo
nel fare carpet superiamo superiamo con
nessuno della speranza al massimo
qualcuno richiederà un autografo
scambiandoli per jack black che parliamo
subito di fatto se non i reali di reale
hai ragione scusate ma cosa tu
ora come mai vederlo non farli una
parola due vetture
vorrei un attimo commentare questo luca
no
commentiamo questo lungo
però bisogno
ciao
un po tutti lo champagne ha voluto così
come fanno adesso facendo
faccio parte segue non riesco a metterle
online devi chiudere ok chiudi e aprì e
trova con l'altra mano
ragazzi che dire qua la creazione del
tortello prosegue guardate quanti che
meraviglia era da uno in braccio in più
da bologna diretto al peggio corso il
vero tema che dice basta finita perché
ho perso la pazienza abbiamo il nostro
bolognese doc che sta preparando un
tortello fatto a mano facevano vedere
bologna pure grande eccoci ragazzi in
cottura alla fine abbiamo fatto anche
dei ravioli perché ci eravamo un po
stufati quindi li mangeremo divertitevi
allenatevi voialtri eco to facci sapere
qualcosa da londra lo potete vedere i
ragazzi sono perfetti tengono la cottura
in maniera egregia
abbiamo finito di guardare star trek di
carne
adesso ci facciamo un giretto in
chinatown
ricordiamo il mondo che in settimana
prossima e francese quindi qui secondo
me ci saranno dragoni e anche un po di
spazzatura
abbiamo la sveglia alle tre e mezza
perché dobbiamo correre in italia dovevo
farlo all'alba che bello eh
chissà se poco a svegliarci
[Musica]
volevamo mangiare leggeri perché ci
speriamo tra pro forma
non proprio
[Musica]
nove le bellezze questo panino
passiamo un attimo fare una piccola
osservazione ma ndo cazzo era la regina
non c'era la reggina ha veramente ha
avuto un sacco di problemi all'interno
della famiglia e quindi la reggina ha
ben pensato di starsene a casa
secondo me è meglio non ha detto
concedere dici che se non sarebbe venuta
va beh possiamo dormire adesso ci
svegliamo prativo un'ora che poi in
realtà andando a milano strano cosa
assurda anche lì è suonata la sveglia
sono le 3 45 del mattino e una domanda
per voi chi secondo voi non ha proprio
chiuso occhio
la cosa mi preoccupa sono sincero e che
sto per andare a fare un lavoro
abbastanza importante al quale tengo
tantissimo a milano un po non so come
farò a rischio di fare un fiore in
quanto ci vuole per arrivare a milano da
londra un'ora e mezza solo
vabbè più o meno lì ma non ci può
mettere un po di più così dormo e allora
partiamo da due cose le considerazioni
dio benedica che ha creato questa specie
di sdraio dentro gli aeroporti in
persone è veramente alle quali io do
tutta la stima e la benedizione di
nostro signore
seconda cosa io non so
però questa giornata che è importante
così ricordato ai polsi